Because dude,
I had a cracked filling and
they took the filling out.
Oh,
and the fucking smell
that came out of my mouth.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Because there was an infection and I
had a wound up getting a root canal.
It like you could hear it like pop
through and then just this fucking shit
breath.
My father is fine.
He was sleeping with his wife,
said you have to go to the dentist.
So why does your breath
is so out of control?
So apparently he had an abscess,
a sack of bacteria in
the back of his mouth.
Well,
when they took the feeling out
and they popped by accident,
the sac,
the nurse through
fucking dentist walked into
the room at that moment
and through the [inaudible] fest.
Ooh,
she just puked
like that.
Yeah.
I never had the balls to
tell someone that breaths.
When you work with them,
you have,
if you work with them,
you have to tell friends where I
would want them to tell me like,
your breath stinks.
I'm going to tell you the worst
one cool thing about black people.
They'll tell you
no problem with that.